hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be going over a pretty unique opening
and that is the Grabbe tack just so
happens to be my most requested video
over the past couple years typically I
respond to people requesting and saying
you should just not play this because
it's not very strong but more and more
people continue to request it so I
thought I'd go ahead and make a video go
over give the key concept for those
people who've never played this
generally because it's not that strong
and then some of the traps that you can
get your opponent into because most
people they don't play it most people
haven't played against it and they just
don't even know where to start with this
so we'll go ahead and get into it
specifically the main lines and then
some of the variations that you may see
from that now some of the things that
you can see right off the bat is this
does weaken the king side of the board
so with that you're generally not
looking to castle on the Kings I know
you still may sometimes but your king
safety really comes from the center of
the board for most of your game so
you're not gonna be pushing your pawns
towards the center very often until
you've established an attack or a
defense and then maybe you decide to
push forward but for the most part
you're going to be attacking from the
outside so more of that hyper modern
defense attacking where you're finding
your bishops you're getting your Knights
involved into the game and you're
attacking from the flanks here pawn to
c4 is gonna be pretty common pawn g4 if
you want to march up the board pawns h4
later on you'll see that in the
variations that we go over usually black
is going to start out with the main line
and that is pawn to d5 this attacks the
center of the board and it also opens up
the door for this LightSquared bishop to
immediately attack this pond right here
on g4 now there's a couple ways that
white can always continue and there's
gonna be some if you look at it is more
textbook like this is a stronger move
but you're not playing the grab attack
for the best possible move from a
textbook standpoint so I'm gonna go over
what I consider the best attacking move
partly it's more fun that way but it's
subjectively almost as strong as some of
the other moves but
think you're gonna get better results
especially if you're playing a human
there's more times that they can fall in
suea traps so those are the lines that
I'm gonna be recommending that you play
if you are gonna opt for the grab attack
it's always gonna start out with Bishop
to g2 fitting kiddo in this bishop
especially if they're playing pawn to d5
you want to attack this pond right here
you don't mind if they take your pawn
here on a g4 you're not playing it
because it's gonna be you know well
protected and hopefully you're not
really interested in the grab attack
because you want to play pawn to h3 like
this is just the most boring opening
that you could possibly play Bishop to
g2 all of a sudden says hey if you want
to take my pawn right here then I can
start to do some things and the first
thing you're gonna be doing is pawn to
c4 this opens up the threat of after the
pawn takes then the bishop can take here
on b7
the LightSquared bishop is left the
building and so all of a sudden in those
sites where a bishop can take this rook
here on a 8 now black doesn't
necessarily have to fall for this and
even if they decide to play Knight to d7
black is gonna still have a fine game
here but it's a much different game than
they may have expected when they came
out here and took this pawn here on g4
because now the bishop can take here on
a8 Queen takes here on 8 pawn to f3 very
important move right here since the
Queen is attacking this rook let's say
the bishop comes back here to f5 and
then Queen up here to a4 this is pinning
down the knight also attacking the pawn
here on c4 so this is gonna be a
completely fine opening for white white
does hold a small advantage in this
position now blacks not always gonna
take this pawn here on c4 this is for
someone that's just not really paying
attention and they don't really see that
this Bishop here on g2 can take our here
more often than not instead of you know
the pawn taking here on c4 you're gonna
see some other variations so we'll go
over some of the main things that you'd
see the first variation that you may see
in this position is pawn to c6
solidifying the pawn chain also blocking
this long light square diagonal which
white is really trying to control in
this position
from here White's gonna play Queen to b3
another theme that you'll see is after
you play pawn to c4 you're really trying
to get the Queen here b3 for two reasons
one is it also controls the center
specifically this d5 square the pond the
queen and the bishop all attacking that
it also attacks this pawn here on b7 so
lots of things that white is trying to
do in this position now you could see
lots of different ways that black tries
to defend this you could see pawn to b6
from here why she's going to take right
here and it's tricky because they can't
really take back with their pawn because
then you're just going to see the Queen
take the Queen is attacking the rook
it's being defended by the bishop as
well so Queen takes bishop takes the
rook is gonna fall blacks in a terrible
position right here but instead you know
we could see the bishop come back here
to d7 okay well now we could say pawn to
d4 maybe Knight to f6 attacking your
pond and then pawn up here to e4 all of
a sudden White has a very strong central
defense and this is a point where it's
okay to start pushing forward in front
of the King Black's not putting any
pressure on white White's now being the
aggressor on the board so you can see
when it's okay to start pushing forward
in the game instead of b6 you may see
black try something else Queen to d7
makes a lot of sense Knight to c3 white
continuing to put more pieces in play
that are going to attack the square in
the center of the board
maybe pawn to e5 as far as just trying
to control the center of the board but
white can now start to gobble up
material Queen takes here if there wants
to be an exchange that's fine white
could recapture with the knight or the
bishop
I think either these are gonna be okay
for white now that was if we see black
play pawn to c6 could also defend with
something like pawn to e6 from here why
it's going to continue the same thing
Queen to b3 now there's a few options
from here maybe we see Knight to c6 then
we see the exchange in the start of the
board now Knight to c3 I think this is
going to be
completely fine for white doesn't have
an advantage necessarily in the board
state because there still is that
weekend king side of the board but I
think white has a very playable position
and has a lot of active pieces now
instead of Knight to c6 you could see
something like pawn to b6 you never
really know exactly how your opponent's
going to respond and sometimes they look
at this they see the threat of queen up
here to b7 and they think the best way
to defend this is pawn to b6 well now we
could take with our pond right here and
they can't really take back because now
Bishop here to e5 this is gonna be very
very bad for them and there's no way to
stop this profitably
now you may initially look at this and
say yes the bishop is attacking the rook
right here and I ate but it's pretty
pretty easy to stop that just pawn here
to c6 but that's not actually the threat
that white has going on instead we have
the bishop and the queen both eyeing
down this pawn here on f7 this is the
weakest square on the board because the
king is the only one defending this now
the king is forced to move then you
could take this material right here on
g8 it's also protected by the Queen here
on b3 s we're just gonna be able to
gobble up into here right here you can
see what a terrible position is this is
for black now and those are just trying
to stop the threat over here on the
Queen side of the board now if we come
back and say what if black now realizes
this and instead plays Bishop up here to
e6 okay well now we're not going to be
taking the rook up here on a a because
we don't want to lose our Queen but now
the bishop could take the pawns gonna
take Queens gonna come up here take that
pawn get material back on the board you
can look at it right here and say White
has more pawns than black all of a
sudden blacks King is out in the open
it's gonna be tough to to thin this
white can start to develop this pieces
White's gonna have a very very good game
in this position you also may see some
other variations pawn to e5 if you think
they're just gonna control the center of
the board had to go ahead and take right
here on d5 maybe Knight to f6 attacking
the pawn Knight up here to c3 defending
it then you can get your queen involved
into the board here to be
three so those are some options instead
of pawn to e5 one thing I have seen
quite often is Knight to f6 and there's
a lot of things to keep in mind if you
do see Knight to f6 one is you want to
get your queen involved to b3 there's
some traps that you have here that are
very common but you also have to be
aware of some traps that you can have
against yourself one of those would be
to lose your queen if you take up here
on b7 and then you don't retreat quick
enough as an example let's say from here
they play pawn to e6 pretty common and
then you take up here on b7 they're just
giving you that material and then they
play Knight here to d7 then you take the
material right here
you played Knight up here to c3
attacking this pawn and then they play
Knights here to c5 your queen is lost
you really need to play something else
you need to get that Queen back to
safety once you play Knight to c3 which
looks like a good move unfortunately
it's not going to because after Knight
to c5 there's no way to hold on to your
queen now you can look at and say what
about Queen to b4 they can't attack it
right here well now we have Knight to d3
check and this is for key in the Queen
but also after the pawn takes the bishop
can come down and take this Queen here
on b4 now back in the position what if
we play Queens who c6 this is going to
be Czech but then black can just bring
his bishop back here to d7 and there's
no way to properly defend that Queen
another thing to look at Queen to b5
this is check but then pawn to c6 that's
gonna put in into our fun maybe the
Queen takes bishop up here to d7 and the
queen is going to fall so just keep that
in mind if you are gonna take the pawn
up here on b7 best thing you need to be
thinking about is how can I retreat to
make sure I do not lose my queen now one
of the most common traps you'll be
putting on your opponent if you play the
grab attack comes from this position but
why it's not gonna be taking the pawn up
here to b7 so if you're worried about
your coin being captured
I just wouldn't worry about taking that
instead I would go ahead and take with
your
pawn right here on d5 and many times
black is gonna fall for this trap
because they feel like they need to take
with their night here on d5 it's
protected it's a great outpost for the
Knights and they just feel like hey if I
take my pawn right here it's just kind
of by itself and then you know what are
they really looking to do here
they don't have an aggressive position
unfortunately for them this is gonna
fall to Queens ua4 check their bishop
over here on g4 is now a sitting duck
it's really tough because they don't
have a lot of material in the Grob
attack to defend this bishop here on g4
they don't want to waste their time
retreating the bishop because White's
generally attacking from the very
beginning and so for me it doesn't
really matter how black continues Knight
to c6 this bishop is gonna fall over
here on g4 now that is an attack if we
look at it from this position after
black plays pawn to e6 you have to be
careful depending on how black could
continue because something you could see
is pawn to c6 now if you look at and say
pawn takes and now the knight takes here
okay well now you look at and say I'm
gonna go ahead and take with my queen up
here to b7 now Knight to d7 and it looks
like that this pawn right here on c6 is
open it's not being defended right now
but one of the things that black has two
are one of the things that white has to
think about is the back rank making it
you look at this and say where's the
back row and that is the bishop or the
Queen takes here on c6 scuse me and then
rook to c8 and this is the threat of if
this Queen moves this Bishop down here
is gonna fall and it is going to be a
checkmate so you know Queen takes here
on d5 and it is going to fall right here
the game is over now if you look at and
say how does white continue right here
well you could see the bishop take the
night here on d5 Queen's gonna fall here
on c6 the bishops gonna recapture here
Queen here to c8
attacking the bishop maybe Bishop takes
your exchanges King takes on d7 yes
white has material on the board but
black does have that
Queen has the bishop pair this is going
to be a position where black is actually
favored and it's gonna be difficult for
white to really continue in the spot has
no pieces or pawns developed in this
position black should have an easy game
its hacking his opponent so just keep
that in mind if you are playing white in
that position just be looking to make
sure that they can't come over bring the
rook here c8 attacking the queen forcing
a move that's gonna end up poorly if you
have to worry about this back right make
here with the rook taking on c1 now we
looked at the more common lines that you
will see you also see some just crazy
openings that people have no idea how to
respond so you could see Knight to f6
simple development move they feel like
this is pretty common I gets they're not
involved it protects this pawn right
here they don't know what you're doing
so hey you're attacking it with your
bishop so I'm just gonna continue my
normal development you're gonna push
forward with g5 you're not playing pawn
up here to g4 because it's this powerful
pawn that you really care about you're
looking to sacrifice that thing as early
as move to so push it up here to g5 now
depending on where they do you're just
gonna chase them around the board Knight
to e4 make some sense pawn to d3 opens
up the board for this light squared
there's dark square bishop to defend
this pawn here on g5 also attacks this
Knight here maybe the knight moves back
here to d6 and then white can take this
material here on a d5 much better if
they bring the Knights back here to c5
but it doesn't look that easy for them
to find it and even from here why it's
gonna have a pretty good game now if we
come back to the beginning and that was
if they played Knight to f6 after d5 you
may still see some people that after
pawn to g4 they just play pawn to e5 and
you're gonna continue with the same
thing Bishop here to g2 and you may even
see Knight to f6 in this position that's
just a common mood that they typically
play after e5 and they're just gonna let
you do your thing they don't know what
you're doing but it's much worse in this
position
after pawn to g5 they no longer have the
option to bring the Knights down here to
e4 before you know they had their pawn
on d5 it was a nice little outpost they
could defend it if white were to capture
what the bishop black does not have that
option here so instead they're gonna
have a few things they can do bring it
back here to g8 which this just feels
terrible for black to waste and move so
early in the game they could bring it
here to h5 White's just going to start
attacking pawn to d4 just starting to
attack the center of the board black has
a knight over here on h5 that's not
doing anything this is gonna be good for
for white or don't want to come down
here to g4 then Y can play pawn to h3
it's gonna be tough for black to not
lose a material in this position really
has to come down and take with his
knight on f2 King's going to come here
take here on f2 yes White has an exposed
King doesn't have a lot of kingside
safety but that's not why you're playing
the grab attack in the first place you
should be happy the fact that you have
some very aggressive pieces right here
and then you're up in material the last
variation we're gonna look at is going
along the same main line after they play
pawn to d5 but now they play something
like pawn to e5 more common than you may
think a lot of people like to control
the center of the board they don't know
what white is up to and so they just say
okay do what you want I'm not gonna do
anything crazy as far as taking material
here cuz I'm not sure what you're up to
and I've heard some people talk about
the fact that if they don't take your
pawn here on g4 but you have the threat
still of this Bishop are on c8 you
should go ahead and defend with pawn to
h3 if you see yourself playing pawn to
h3 in the grab attack you're doing it
wrong play something else you should
probably play something else in general
but if you play the grab attack play
something more fun they're way better
options that give you more fun than
playing pawn to h3 the one that I like
the most is pawn to g5 it says hey you
can now take with your queen but your
Queens the only defender on the square
on d5 so sure go ahead and
take my pawn I'm gonna recapture with my
bishop here on D vibe I'm taking your
Center pawn what do you want to do now
and maybe they defend with pawn to c6
okay well now we're gonna play pawn to
d3 opening up for a dark square bishop
to attack the Queen forcing them to do
something now if they continue along
this G file you need to be aware so
let's say Queen to g6 you need to play
Bishop to f3 you would really like to
play your Bishop back here to b3 but the
threats you have to be aware of is Queen
down here to g2 getting ready to take
our rook on h1 that is something black 2
always gonna be looking at you have to
be aware of that so play Bishop back
here to f3 if instead they play Queen to
e7 perfect now you can play Bishop back
to b3 and you still have the thread
attacking this f7 square this is
definitely the way to go
now instead of pawn to c6 you could see
Knight to f6 simple development move
attacks the bishop white doesn't have a
huge attack right now and so you may see
this more often than not I recommend you
do not play pawn to d3 attacking the
Queen the Queen's gonna come back
something like g6 since it can't really
retreat to e7 and then you're really
forced to play that Bishop to f3 to stop
the Queen coming down here to g2 but
unfortunately pawn to e4 is a pain pain
to play against so just don't do it it's
going to it's gonna end poorly for you
just take my word for it instead once
they play Knight to f6
you can play Knight to f3 now if you
look at this you say well can't they
play Queen down here to g2 and they can
and that's the whole point of why you
did that this is another trap that many
players are gonna fall into because they
think this is going to be just a
terrible move for white but well white
can actually do is take with their
Bishop here on f7 check this is gonna
force the King to come down take this
material this is an important square
with the King right here at f7 the
reason for
that is now we can play rook to G one
can't take this rook because Knights
protecting it tank can't take the night
because the pawns protecting it can't
take this pawn over here because the
Knights protecting it's attacking this
entire G file so all I can really do is
play Queen to h3 and now Knight up here
to g5 forking the King going this Queen
is now going to fall so that's why I
recommend play that Knight to f3 this is
something that until you play the grab
attack which unfortunately I can say
that I have played more than I would
like to just as I was prepping for this
video it's just you feel like you should
be playing pawn to d3 computer engines
will even tell you this is the better
move but humans fall way more for Knight
to f3 because they just feel like they
need to bring that Queen down here to G
- so that's the move I recommend also at
the beginning just don't play that pawn
to h3 there's way better moves that you
can do so that is the grab attack
hopefully for those people who have been
requesting it you like this if you don't
like the grab attack at all my guess is
you probably never even watched the
video or you watch the first two minutes
made a comment that said the grab attack
is terrible why did you make this video
that's going to be completely fine but
if you made it to the end thank you for
watching not a recommended opening but I
still think it's fun to play really any
opening and chess can be fun depending
on who you're playing and if you're
playing a blitz game try this out see if
there's some variations you like in here
my guess is you'll find that black
really has no idea how to defend this
you get very aware of how to attack your
opponent's they'll fall for a lot of the
traps we've talked about and it'll end
up being better than you think so
hopefully you guys enjoy this thanks for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
video